it's an exciting day tomorrow a rare
event leap day tomorrow and the way the
stock market is going there's gonna be a
lot of leaping market lost six trillion
dollars but this way I know pretty soon
that adds up to real money
Bloomberg is not even sure anymore he
can buy the country I mean it and of
course that's because of the coronavirus
now look is this serious yes it is the
CDC is now calling at the kovat 19 and
you know a disease is serious when they
give it a rap name
but panic no we should not panic and it
doesn't merit panic first of all we live
in LA the air is so toxic anything that
comes out of anybody's mouth is killed
immediately it doesn't germs viruses but
will life change yes well you just have
to take more precautions now I mean just
assume everyone is infectious the same
warning they give contestants on The
Bachelor one person in this country who
was way ahead of this Melania when
someone tries to touch her hand boy she
slaps it away now fortunately her
husband Donald Trump is in charge and
when I say fortunately I mean oh [ __ ]
this would be a nice time wouldn't it
too heavy president who doesn't talk out
of his ass and think with his dick and
eat with his hands
[Applause]
we don't have that we have a president
who thinks this coronavirus is a minor
annoyance like the common cold or the
Constitution of the United States one
who appoints as the person to head up
this massive medical emergency Mike
Pence who doesn't even believe in
evolution
really it's like making Jared ambassador
to Funkytown now we have one we have a
president who just keeps telling us
crazy lies that contradict everything
the CDC is saying he says the virus is
ending they say of course not it's
inevitable it's going up who are you
gonna believe infectious disease experts
or the guy who [ __ ] stormy Daniels
without a condom
because that's from sata2 can you blame
him this attitude is I [ __ ] raw I raw
dog porn stars I eat a diet that would
gag a raccoon I want an election where I
got the fewest votes [ __ ] you science
[ __ ] you math I commit crimes and my
lawyers go to jail reality is for losers
he said yesterday the virus it's going
to disappear one day like a miracle it
will just disappear really mr. president
because just hoping that it'll be gone
I've tried that with you when it doesn't
work
now listen we've known each other a long
time right right we known each other
okay so I'm gonna tell you my message
we're we're you're gonna hear some scary
things and some of them are really going
to be scary today it was in the news in
Hong Kong they think a dog tested
positive they think it's just
environmental contamination but just
just in case I told my two dogs bark
into your elbow and do not drink out of
the same toilet but just please remember
what the great Jimmy Breslin once said
the message of TV he said is stay inside
and watch more TV it is very important
to remember all the other times that
cable news was telling you that we were
all going to die SARS and MERS and Ebola
and the swine flu and bird flu and this
flu and that flu please say it with me
now
flus will not replace us flus will
replace us
you